governor andrew cuomo declares a
disaster emergency on gun violence
our most powerful institutions have been
hijacked by radicals and our education
system is now rife with critical theory
of all sorts i'm ben shapiro this is the
ben shapiro show
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn for peace of mind whenever
you go online visit expressvpn.com
i'll get to all the news in just one
moment first you know when you go online
and then you
pop onto incognito mode you're probably
thinking to yourself i am now incognito
after all it's called
incognito mode unfortunately incognito
mode doesn't actually protect you
from nearly anything in fact your
activity might still be visible to your
employer your school or your internet
service provider
how can they even call it incognito to
really stop people from seeing the sites
you visit
you need to do what i do and use
expressvpn
think about all the times you've used
wi-fi at a coffee shop a hotel even at
your parents house without expressvpn
every site you visit could be logged by
the admin of that network
that is still true even when you are in
so-called incognito mode
what's more your home internet provider
i'm talking comcast att whatever can
also see
and record your browsing data in the
united states they can sell that data to
advertisers
expressvpn is an app that encrypts all
your network data reroutes it through a
network of secure servers so your
private online activity stays just to
that
private it's really easy to use
expressvpn you click one button you
download it you click another button
you're ready to go
so stop letting strangers invade your
online privacy protect yourself at
expressvpn.com
use my link expressvpn.com to get three
extra months for free that's
expressvpn.com
to learn more alrighty so it is a common
facet of all governments throughout
human history
that whenever a government seeks to
maximize its own power it declares an
emergency
we saw this most prominently with kobet
when the government still has not let go
the emergency measures put in place to
try and fight a virus that nobody knew
anything about even though we now have
enough information to reopen even though
we now have a vaccine
we see all over the world there are
places still locking down for no
apparent reason
we see with regard to virtually every
major topic
of the day a desire by governmental
actors to declare an emergency
specifically
so they can then take greater control on
the right you might see president trump
for example declare a border emergency
even though it isn't technically an
emergency in the sense that it
actually invokes emergency powers if you
declare something in emergency people
are more likely to give you the means
necessary in order to solve the
emergency
and so governmental actors always right
left and center have a
deep desire and abiding desire to
declare everything in emergency
so that people will throw up their hands
and say well in an emergency you need to
call
in the brute squad and it's an emergency
that means it's time for caesar
to take control dictators rarely gain
power without there being some sort of
emergency that precedes the dictatorship
in which the people throw up their hands
and they say i don't care how it gets
done it needs to get done
and we need somebody to step in and do
this thing right now and right now in
the united states
the side that is most commonly invoking
emergencies
in order to centralize power is the
political left
without question the latest indicator of
this is andrew cuomo this is a dude who
fell in love with power during copen
when he was widely championed as this
unbelievable governor even though half
the people in his state died and he was
killing all the olds
andrew cuomo did a horrible job in new
york didn't matter he was celebrated
as the greatest politician in america
even though he is a nasty
cruel person according to members of his
own party he is
he is a botchery of a governor who was
shipping covet-positive old people back
into nursing homes
in order that they could presumably
spread that disease and then hiding the
stats by suggesting that if you died at
a hospital you didn't die
in a nursing home although all while he
was sexually harassing the staff so
really just a genius of leadership
remember just a few months ago
when andrew cuomo was supposedly on the
outs remember there are all these women
who came forward and suggested that he
had sexually harassed and or assaulted
them remember that
and and then it just sort of went away
because the rule in american politics is
not the rule from the dark knight where
you either
die a hero or live long enough to become
a villain it's either die a hero live
long enough to become a villain or live
even longer and become a hero again and
this is what's happened with ralph
northam in virginia who could be just as
racist as he wanted 30 years ago
everybody would call for him to leave if
you stick around long enough joe biden
will campaign with you
andrew cuomo can sexually harass the
help as much as he wants and kill all
the olds in new york
and eventually if you just stick around
long enough everything will go away
politicians who brazen it out are the
ones who are doing the best in the
modern era
for sure but andrew cuomo bottom line is
the dude fell in love with control he
loves control and this is not rare for
politicians from new york
there is something to the notion of of
populist leftist states
where people in control people in charge
love the power and they are constantly
declaring emergencies and again when you
declare an emergency you get to grab
control of the reigns so new york has
seen this radical increase in crime
particularly violent crime in new york
city and it's very it's very very
obvious why this is happening we've seen
this massive spike
in violence in every major metropolitan
area run by a democrat across the united
states
during covid and the reason that you've
seen that is because of the
george floyd movement the the blm
movement that was specifically dedicated
at
kneecapping the police and suggesting
the police were systemically racist it
was time to defund them
that the big problem in america's major
metropolitan area is that there were too
many police officers and the police
officers
were just too terrible and just too
brutal and so the police stopped
policing many police officers quit
the police were underfunded and they
were told not to enforce the law
you know i i received much mockery when
i suggested that new york city
mayoral candidates ought to be talking
about banning crime the reason i said
that is because
they literally are allowing crime to
take place they're just saying we're not
even going to prosecute crime
in fact there's a story i believe out of
los angeles recently that suggested that
the new d.a there is now declaring that
low-level crimes will never be
prosecuted essentially
okay so the reason we've seen this
massive uptick in crime is because when
you tolerate crime you get more of this
this is a very robust social science
finding when you want crime to go away
you need more cops
but democrats don't want to admit that
the police are the good guys
they don't want to admit that the cops
are overwhelmingly people who are
standing between them and disorder
and so instead they've come up with a
new math and the math is we do have an
emergency but it's not an emergency
having to do with crime
in which we would give more power to the
police to crack down on crime no the
emergency
is guns the emergency is gun violence
and you said yourself wait a second
aren't guns just an inanimate object
and haven't the number of guns in
circulation in the united states risen
dramatically since
like say 1994 to now while crime rates
particularly violent crime rates
declined up until about 2014 2015.
so there's no correlation there yes you
might say that if you're an intelligent
human but if you're a democrat
if you're a democrat by the name of
andrew cuomo you do have an emergency
and the emergency
is guns and if you can declare a public
health emergency
on the basis of guns then you can do
whatever you want in the same way that
lori lightfoot in chicago has now
declared racism a public health
emergency
and then suggested i need more power in
order to solve this emergency andrew
cuomo has now declared
gun violence in emergency in new york
state
now again that's not a description
of a thing right there you can say
there's a violence emergency and
a crime emergency because those are
activities in which people engage gun
violence is a tool
okay guns are a tool violence is an
activity to suggest that the tool is the
emergency is of course nonsensical
on its face but as long as you invoke an
emergency you're fine so here's andrew
cuomo yesterday declaring
a disaster emergency on gun violence
we're post covered but there's still
low tide inequality and
it is still a matter of life and death
we went from one epidemic to another
epidemic
we went from covid to the epidemic of
gun violence
and the fear and the death that goes
along with it
it's been all over the newspapers it is
undeniable
it's unbelievable okay so the the point
is that
he says that more people in new york
state were shot last weekend over july
4th and died of covert
that's true but there was no correlation
between covet which was an actual
viral emergency in which people were
giving each other a disease and
overwhelming the hospitals
right in which the government you can
make the argument had to step in and
tell people to stay home for a bit
while they figured out what exactly was
going on said the hospital system
particularly in new york wasn't
overwhelmed
and gun violence which as it turns out
is not transmissible
right there is not a single person who
has ever committed an act of gun
violence in the united states
who then transmitted it to another
person who then was
had to engage in gun violence because
they were transmitting a disease
but again the point is that once you
declare an emergency you can do whatever
you want so we'll get to exactly what
andrew cuomo is proposing in just one
second first
let's talk about a simple fact when you
start a business you really don't think
about hr very much it's sort of an
afterthought it's like toby from the
office right
but if you don't actually take a look at
your hr issues they can kill you they
can come back and just destroy your
business
which is why you need bambi when you're
running a business
hr issues are really important wrongful
termination suits minimum wage
requirements labor regulations
you need to make sure you are in
compliance hr manager salaries are not
cheap they average 70 000 bucks a year
bambi is about b-a-m-b-e-e it was
created specifically for small business
you can get a dedicated hr manager craft
hr policy maintain your compliance
all for just 99 bucks a month with bambi
you can change hr from your biggest
liability to your biggest strength
your dedicated hr manager is available
by phone email or real-time chat
from onboarding determinations that
customize your policies to fit your
business
and help you manage your employees
day-to-day all for just 99 bucks a month
they're month-to-month no hidden fees
you can cancel any time you didn't start
that business because you wanted to
handle hr so why not let bambi do it for
you go to bambi.com
shapiro right now to schedule your free
hr audit that is bambi.com
shapiro spelled bam to the b-e-e dot com
shapiro go check them out right now okay
so the governor has now
because he declared an emergency
allocated 139 million dollars to address
shootings
and what exactly is he attempting to do
well he had some tweets about what
exactly he was attempting to do did the
governor
so he tweeted out the gun industry is
the only industry in america with
immunity from civil lawsuits it's an
insult to victims of gun violence today
i'm signing legislation to reinstate
public nuisance liability for gun
manufacturers in new york state
and then he thanks a couple of democrats
okay so let's start with what this means
number one this is legally nonsensical
the gun industry is not the only
industry in america that is legally
immune to liability
the gun industry is the only industry in
america where democrats have attempted
to craft a new form of liability for gun
manufacturers suggesting
that normally when it comes to products
liability there are a few different sort
of defects that you can sue somebody for
you can sue somebody because there's a
manufacturing liability issue
right you you bought a crib and there's
a manufacturing defect in the crib
and god forbid your child gets hurt you
can sue the company based on the
manufacturing defect you can do design
defect they designed the crib in such a
way that it was likely to do harm right
design defect this is all products
liability kind of stuff there is no
product liability
when there's no design defect in the
crib and no manufacturing defect in the
crib and instead you took your baby and
you slammed your baby's head against the
crib
okay same thing with a gun okay a gun
that is properly designed is designed to
shoot
okay if the sun if the gun blows up in
your face that's a product's liability
suit
if the gun is so poorly designed that it
damages somebody you are not shooting at
then that's a product liability suit but
if you use a gun
for its intended purpose or even for
it's not intended purpose but
it is it operates as designed
it is treated like any other tool
democrats have tried to say that a gun
is inherently dangerous and therefore
should be subject to liability if a bad
person uses a gun for a bad thing
that is what he's talking about there
when he says that there should also be
public nuisance liability public
nuisance
is when a corporation pollutes a river
that's what public nuisance is
the corporation has downstream effects
polluting the environment
it is not a public nuisance when you
manufacture a product that somebody buys
and the person misuses the product
any more than a chainsaw manufacturer is
engaged in public nuisance
when a when a horror movie villain
decides to go through a sorority house
with a chainsaw that's not how any of
that works
it is a violation of basic black letter
law what he's pushing here will be
struck down immediately by any court
with half a brain obviously
but again the point here is not to
actually solve the problem the pointer
is to accrete power
in the center of power namely under
andrew cuomo's auspices
he tweeted out over the july fourth
weekend more people in new york state
were shot than died of covid gun
violence is an epidemic
no it is not it does not fit any of the
definitional terms of an epidemic
none okay the definition of an epidemic
is is not
a person did a thing that has no impact
on me
and that's it that's that's that's not
an epidemic
the definition is the widespread
occurrence of an infectious disease in a
community at a particular time
dictionary definition
is this a widespread disease do you
catch gun violence
it's so maddening but if you change the
definitions you can declare a public
health emergency he says we should treat
gun violence as a public health crisis
so according to democrats
just to be straight about this we have a
public health emergency of racism
and of gun violence those are the two
things we have a public health emergency
about
in the united states interesting take in
that neither of those is a public health
emergency
what exactly are these strategies that
andrew cuomo is pushing he wants to
deploy a public health approach to gun
violence
but he's going to lock you in your home
and force you to do a masquerade target
hot spots
using science and data oh you mean doing
the things that police
used to be allowed to do but now are no
longer allowed to do because if you
target
gun violence hot spots
disproportionately this will affect
minority communities because that's
where much of the gun violence is taking
place like it's fun when he says things
like we're going to target hot spots
using science and data
literally that was comstat introduced by
william bratton in the 1990s and then
it was declared that this was a form of
racial profiling because it turns out a
huge
amount of gun violence particularly in
major metros happens in
poor minority areas positive engagement
for at-risk youth so
that that's going to change things
double funding in proven violence
intervention
programs get illegal guns off the
streets keep guns out of the hands of
dangerous people
strengthen the police community
relationship okay how's any of this
solving done by how about like more
funding for the cops
how about let the cops do their job but
again it's not about any of that
it's about pretending to solve a problem
while declaring an emergency so again
you can accrue
more power and use it to cram down your
particular
point of view and this is how the left
operates these days
everything is an emergency and if it's a
solvable emergency
then you just ignore the solution in
order so you can declare a broader
emergency
we'll get to more of that in just one
second first let us talk
about the fact that your sleeve quality
very often it is compromised so
you know for me my kids are waking me up
so early in the morning i gotta tell you
i didn't drink coffee until i had kids
and now i
guzzle it like it's going out of style
but it also means that i have to have a
great mattress because when i'm on that
mattress i cannot be tossing and turning
i do not have the time for that i need a
mattress made just for me
everybody's unique helix knows that they
have several different mattress models
to choose from they've got soft
medium and firm mattresses mattresses
great for cooling you down if you sleep
hot
even a helix plus mattress for plus size
folks so if you're looking for a
mattress you take the quiz you order the
mattress
and the mattress comes right to your
door ship for free you don't ever need
to go to a mattress store again
helix is awesome you don't need to take
my word for it helix was awarded the
number one best overall mattress pick of
2020 by gq and wired magazine just go to
helixsleep.com take their two minutes
leave quizzes they will match you to a
customized mattress that'll give you
the best sleep of your life they've got
a 10 year warranty you get to try it out
for a hundred nights risk free they'll
even pick it up for you if you don't
love it
but you will helix is offering up to two
hundred dollars off all their mattress
orders and two free pillows
for our listeners at helix sleep.com
it's about as good as deals you're gonna
get 200 bucks off all mattress orders
and two free pillows for our listeners
with a mattress made just for you the
way my wife and i have one it is
fantastic helixsleep.com to get started
all right so emergency breeds control
emergency breeds control for the left
and so everything is an emergency
as i've said the declaration by the left
that gun violence is an emergency and
therefore
the governor can literally just invoke
emergency powers that's dangerous stuff
as we'll talk about in a bit they do the
same thing with climate change climate
change is an emergency
therefore give us power we don't need
checks and balances we don't need
considered public policy we don't need
to battle this out
we actually just take control and we
solve the problem
because the problem is an emergency and
the big
public health emergency of our day is of
course
racism and the the art just gets longer
and rolls more as time goes on and as
the emergency
becomes deeper and more profound the the
left's argument is that america
is in the crisis of of race and uh
crisis of racial division reckoning a
reckoning
now normally when there is a reckoning
what that means is that the people who
are guilty pay
right when when there's a reckoning it
means that somebody is guilty and that
person pays that person has had a
reckoning
in the united states the way reckoning
works is that we are all supposed to
take
blame for a bunch of crap that we didn't
do specifically so that people can
game the system and take control of it
that's effectively the argument that is
made by the left
these days and this argument has now
made its way in nearly every major
institution
in american society that we are
experiencing such an emergency that
all aspects of the institutional
structures of the united states must be
activated in order to fight this
emergency it's like world war ii
but with race right world war ii we had
to commandeer all of industry we had to
use all of it to produce the weaponry
necessary in order to defeat the nazis
world war ii
we had to regiment the population to act
in particular ways and make particular
sacrifices
we had to hell draft every eligible man
over the age of 18
in order to fight in a war this is a war
the left loves the language of war you
may notice right it's a war on poverty
it's a war on racism
it's a war on inequality it's always a
war why does the left love the language
of war so much
the reason they love the language of war
is because war requires regimentation
war requires top down control
now they tend to apply the term war to
things
that can never be defeated a racism can
never be defeated
racism can be mitigated you can change
legal structures
to prevent racism from benefiting people
for example
you can stop jim crow but racism as a
phenomenon in the human heart can never
be defeated
the left loves declaring wars you want
to talk about endless wars and people
talk about endless wars in iraq and
afghanistan those were not endless wars
but
put that aside the actual endless wars
are the wars the left declares we've
still not reached the end of the war on
drugs declared by the left in the 60s we
still have not reached the end
of the war on poverty declared by the
left in the 60s we still have not
reached the end of the war on racism
declared by the left in the 60s
why because these are things that will
never go away
and that's the point the more they don't
go away the more the war is endless the
more control you need
during the vietnam war lyndon baines
johnson engaged in a military strategy
egged on by his idiot secretary of
defense robert mcnamara
of graduated escalation graduated
escalation was the notion
that we were going to instead of just
flooding the zone in vietnam
with an overwhelming number of troops
and thereby defeating the vietcong
quickly
instead what we were going to do is
we're going to gradually ratchet up the
pressure and eventually the viet cong
would probably learn
that they shouldn't screw with us well
that didn't work but the notion of
graduated escalation is exactly
how the left treats government
involvement in these wars we will
gradually escalate the amount of
government control
and the goal there is precisely the
opposite of what graduated escalation
was supposed to accomplish in vietnam
namely the end of the war
here graduated escalation is supposed to
make you accustomed
to the government being more in control
of your life and to the institutions of
power
being shifted and twisted into tools of
the government
so slowly you don't even notice so
slowly that the the
roots of ideology grow deep into the
bedrock of the foundational systems of
the country
and then it's too late to uproot them
it's too late to change them
this is the goal of the left and when
this is challenged people go nuts
well this is challenge people go crazy
and that's the current debate that
you're seeing over critical race theory
for example
or teaching in the schools the left has
spent the last 60 years in this country
attempting to infiltrate every major
institution with radical ideas
about what humanity should be and who
should control other people
and now when it's challenged they're
very angry that you've noticed
they're very angry that you've seen it
and so
they're fighting back in major ways or
declaring that this stuff is just not a
big deal why are you even noticing why
is it even a big deal
and it is nearly every major institution
in american society
now i once again here pitch my upcoming
book the authoritarian moment it is
about this it is about how every major
institution in american society has been
weaponized and militarized
by the art and left over the course of
the last six decades
and how these institutions need to be
renormalized all it would have taken
is that apathetic metal standing up on
its hind legs and saying no
it's happening late but it's starting to
happen but it needs to happen because
the reality is the left continues to
declare these emergencies
these emergencies are necessary in order
for them to once again
centralize all power in themselves and
it's happening in the institutions you'd
least expect
like for example the us military it's
amazing to see the left defend the
military only
and only to really only when the
military
is indoctrinating its soldiers in
woke-ism when the military is doing its
actual job
namely breaking things and protecting
people when when
the military does its job abroad then
the military is bad and brutal and
vicious and imperialist and colonialist
when the military is a tool for social
engineering whereby we cram down
on america's fighting men and women
bizarre radical notions about race in
the united states then that is a good
thing
that's when the military is at its best
when it's an indoctrination system
which is why the uk daily mail is
reporting today a u.s air force academy
professor
backs critical race theory for all
troops says the constitution
created inequality that george
washington was a racist and that us
domestic and foreign policy is shaped by
racism
according to the uk daily mail a united
states air force academy professor has
argued critical race theory should be
taught to all cadets so they can
understand how the united states was
quote unquote
shaped by racism now this is the thing
to understand about critical race theory
critical race theory is not just one of
many theories critical race theory
has a praxis component okay praxis is
latin for practice
it has a it has a component in which you
are expected to engage in activism
critical race theory is not
an analytic tool for examining the
universe it is an activist
wing of the radical left a critical race
theory is not just a theory any more
than gender theory is just a theory it
is a way of approaching the world that
calls for activism it requires activism
and it suggests that you are complicit
in the systems of power
unless you engage in precisely that
activism
so when people say well how do why why
shouldn't we teach critical race theory
because you can't
teach critical race theory unless you're
doing so critically which they don't
want you to do
you can't teach critical race theory
without also teaching that you are
complicit in racism white supremacy
heteronormativity
bigotry of all sorts if you are not
tearing down the system actively
it's like teaching marxist activism in
class not marxism as a theory
marxist activism in class that's what
critical race theory is with regard to
race
political scientist lynn chandler garcia
said the constitution
brought about inequality and that george
washington was a racist she argued the
history of the united states proved that
racism has shaped both foreign
and domestic policy garcia teaches the
marxist theory at the univ
at the u.s air force academy in colorado
springs she said she agreed with joint
chiefs of staff chairman general mark
milley who recently told congress
critical race theory is not unpatriotic
that is a lie it is deeply unpatriotic
its essence is unpatriotic it overtly
argues capitalism has to be dismantled
individual rights have to be dismantled
because those are just mere facades
for hierarchies of power okay so now
this stuff is being taught to our cadets
garcia writes in the washington post
cadets like all military members
take an oath to defend the constitution
with their lives so it's crucial they
have a sensitive understanding of that
constitution
in my classes cadets learn about the
ideals embedded in this founding
document we explore the liberalist
theories that promote these ideals and
we embrace our democratic system of
government but
we also acknowledge the united states
was founded on a duality liberalism and
equal rights on the one hand
inequality in egalitarianism and
second-class citizenship on the other
yes clearly we want the people who have
vowed to give their lives to protect the
constitution to believe that the thing
that they are giving their lives to
defend
is a racist document that is rife with
inequality and in fact enshrines it
in america's fundamental law vile and
disgusting but again
when you're fighting the emergency of
racism everything is on the table guys
racism is such an emergency in american
life in a country in which
black people have a higher household
income than any other country on earth
bar none
in which black people have more power in
america's institutions than any other
country on earth bar none right in
like any other diverse country i should
say because they're presumably countries
that have significantly less diversity
in the united states
in which black people hold an enormous
amount of power but
not nearly as powerful countries as the
united states just a corrective there
the the basic idea that black people are
experiencing an emergency with regard to
race in the united states in 2021 is
patently insane again
the emergency is the point we'll get to
that in just one second first
let's talk about something special you
can do for your family so let me tell
you about this unbelievably cool service
so on my phone i have all these
beautiful pictures of my family right
but then and you do too and you don't do
anything with them what if
there were a service that could allow
you to get those photos produced into a
beautiful object that you can then put
on the shelf put in your house
put on your office desk okay this is
where my photo comes in
we take photos of special moments
together after a long year off and after
you take that photo
what you do is make it physical you go
to myphoto.com it is awesome it is easy
to use
it takes literally two minutes to create
a special product for your own wall or
shelf they make great gifts for loved
ones they are beautiful
and they really look great my photo
prints your image directly on acrylic
glass metal and more you need to go to
myphoto.com and check it out that's
myphoto.com
i have a bunch of objects from my photo
that i've ordered they they grace
basically every mantle in my house
pictures of my kids pictures of me and
my wife they're just beautiful
they really shine because we had them
printed on acrylic it's pretty
spectacular order today you'll get 20
off your order which will arrive in just
five days prices start at just 12 bucks
use code ben
get 20 off today it's not just like a
flat picture that you printed out on
like a little piece of paper that's
gonna rip or fall apart
it is a permanent object it's great go
to myphoto.com right now again that is
myphoto.com
okay so in the u.s military we are now
teaching this stuff because again
emergency requires it it requires it
and this is exactly the case that is
made
for example by raytheon so our defense
contractors so private industry
takes a hint from government they take a
hint from all the other major
institutions in the united states they
have to please their bosses in the
government
and so what they do is they've started
to cram down critical race theory on
their own employees again in order to
solve the emergency
everything must be weaponized every
every aspect of american society must be
drafted into this war on racism
even though again racism is at the
lowest abbott has ever been in human
history
we will uh it is a it is a war that is
that is taking over the streets of the
united states
so chris ruffo who's been doing
unbelievably great work with regard to
calling out critical race theory and the
teaching of
quote unquote anti-racist propaganda
in in america's corporate world raytheon
forced its um
employees to in well or encouraged its
white employees to confront their
privilege reject check the principle
of equality and defund the police
they've
launched their own critical race theory
program in coordination with blue ocean
brain hey here's a little bit of their
guide and it's worth going to
going through a little bit in in detail
here stronger together
is what the guide is is titled
commitment to diversity and inclusion
takes all of us they say
ceo action was founded on a shared
belief that diversity equity and
inclusion is a societal issue
not a competitive one and that
collaboration and bold action from the
business community especially ceos is
vital to driving change at scale you see
these ceos they have to maintain control
over you
because they are the greatest right just
as the left has always pined for a
top-down organized economy
in which a few big bosses get to run the
whole show so too with societal change
the ceos will guide us
take the i act on pledge they encourage
their employees at raytheon
we all contribute to our company culture
make a commitment to foster an inclusive
workplace
through your behavior by signing the i
act on pledge i pledge to check my bias
speak up for others and show up for all
i will check my own biases and take
meaningful action to understand and
mitigate them i will initiate meaningful
complex sometimes difficult
conversations with my friends and
colleagues
i will ask myself do my actions and
words reflect
the value of inclusion oh so beautiful
this is all in fighting racism
don't worry it gets a lot worse a lot
lot worse
let's continue they recommend developing
intersectional allyship
in the workplace ooze him for some
intersectional allyship so how can you
be a really good ally well first you
have to acknowledge your privilege
and intersectionality a collection of
unearned advantages this is what
privilege is a collection of unearned
advantages
both visible and invisible based on a
person's social identity
or group membership now one of the
things here that's really interesting is
they say a collection of unearned and on
is in parentheses so if there's a
collection of earned advantages that's
not privileged anymore right
privilege is where you didn't earn it
but they say that even if you earned it
maybe you didn't earn it
privilege is relational and situational
while everyone has some degree of
privilege the corresponding advantages a
person receives
are based on where they are and who they
are with you see it depends on your
societal status if you're a white man
you have had
all the privileges if you are in fact an
asian man who earns more than the white
man apparently not
how do you become an ally well you use
your everyday privilege
privilege says this program over again
at raytheon a defense contractor
privilege is often ignorable unless you
don't have it as award-winning
psychologist and professor
at new york university's stern school of
business dolly true writes
in america if you're white or christian
or able-bodied or straight or
english-speaking these particular
identities are easy to forget
this is called ordinary privilege
because these identities and traits
easily blend in
with the people and norms around us the
question for allies is this how can you
use your privilege
to help others first identify your
privilege consider those aspects of your
identity you think about the least
be it your gender or ethnicity or sexual
orientation once you pinpoint your
ordinary privileges
you can better utilize them to help
people who don't share the same ones
you can learn about others disadvantages
you can do this by increasing your
awareness in your own life and looking
beyond
the world in general you can speak up
just as the luxury to ignore
microaggressions and other injustices is
a tenet of privilege
action is the cornerstone of allyship
right so you have to speak up
no more microaggressions you know like
treating other people like normal human
beings who are capable of
shying off a joke or something no you
have to speak up and not only that you
have to step aside so which is it these
are in conflict right you have to speak
up but also step aside
recognizing your privilege also means
recognizing when other voices
are more important than your own and
this means
that you have to shut up shut up be sure
to amplify others instead of attempting
to speak for them
yes you have to be quiet says the
raytheon program
straightness is a powerful example of
privilege if you're a straight person
it's likely you can go long periods
without consciously considering how your
sexual orientation
impacts how you interact with the world
actually as it turns out in a free
society you pretty much go all the time
without considering how your sexual
orientation affects your place in the
world because no one cares
also raytheon suggests pro-inclusion tip
someone's wraiths or ethnicity isn't a
taboo
topic talk openly about it to appeal to
people's conscious values and challenge
their unconscious biases yes this is
good you should walk up to people you
should immediately label them by raise
and you should identify everybody's race
they say including those who are white
in any conversation you should say as a
white male or
i'm going to shut up because i am a
white male or you should just
i think a great way to start a dinner
party is to just go around and have
everybody name their race
i think that that's a great way to start
a dinner party also
shut up right notice it it all comes
down to shut up pro inclusion tip
according to again
a raytheon educational program listen to
the experiences of others
especially those with marginalized
identities who often don't have an equal
say in decision making give them the
floor in meetings or on calls even if it
means silencing yourself to do so you
learn more when you listen than when you
speak anyway so it's a win-win
unless apparently you're a member of a
marginalized community in which case
everybody else is supposed to shut up
and you should never listen ever ever
ever because those people have nothing
to teach you because
obviously they are a member of the
privileged class and then this is i
think my favorite part of the program
they explain things to say to black
people and not to say to black people
which is not dictatorial and insane in
any way
again this is being taught to our
defense contractors
what not to say to your black colleagues
right now i'm scared to say the wrong
thing to you you shouldn't say that
because this asks your black colleague
to either console you or help you figure
out what to say
and that isn't fair you also should not
say i hope and pray things change soon
this shows you mean well but meaning
well isn't enough
you have to do the work i can't wait for
things to calm down and get back to
normal
this says that your comfort is more
important than the message of
anti-racism
no no you're supposed to you're supposed
to talk about what a victim the other
person is
you're supposed to say things like i'm
taking steps to become a better ally
i'm shutting down racist comments on my
team i'm supporting the fight against
racism by calling my representatives
backing black businesses and or xyz
right this is where you move from the
theory to the praxis component
do all the things we want you to do or
you are a racist do all the things we
want you to do
or you are complicit in the systemic
injustices of american life
also you're supposed to say things like
i realize my discomfort is a fraction of
what you are feeling
according to one of the teachers black
people are quote exhausted mentally
drained frustrated stressed barely
sleeping
scared and overwhelmed feelings which
demand empathy and action
all of them like every single black
person is exhausted mentally drained
frustrated stressed barely sleeping
oh and then we get the obligatory kamala
harris communist slide
in which we find out that equality is
unequal because when you give everybody
equal
rights under the law then some people
finish behind other people
instead what we have to do is we have to
build ramps and give people affirmative
boxes
in order so that everybody can can get
ahead you see the the problem with this
particular
[Music]
the problem with this particular equity
versus uh equality
slide this famous cartoon is that the
the real cartoon would not involve the
person on the left the tallest person
so for for those who who are not seeing
this visually
the equality slide they say equality is
bad because equality
doesn't take into account people's
pre-existing conditions and the fact
that we are not all created equal in all
respects right some of us
are created smarter some dumbest i'm
taller some shorter et cetera so it
shows a slide of
three people behind a fence trying to
watch a game apparently illegally
because they should be buying tickets
and uh and the person on the left
is tall the person in the middle is
short and the person on the right
hand side of the of the little slide is
in a wheelchair
so the short person can barely see and
the person in the wheelchair can't see
at all
equity is where we build a giant ramp so
that the person in the wheelchair can
now see over the fence and where we add
a we take a box away from the tall guy
and give it to the short person
to ensure that she can see as well okay
there's only one problem
when it comes to the equity the left is
pushing it is a zero sum game
it is not a system where everybody gets
more out of it and no one loses it is
not pareto optimal in the economic
terminology
instead what the equity slide should
actually show
is chopping off the legs of the guy on
the left and then
sewing them on to the person in the
middle
who because she's still better off than
the person in the wheelchair then has to
chop off her arms
and those can be used as a sort of props
to prop up the wheelchair see
it equity is a bloody business gang when
you start
deciding that you are going to privilege
certain populations at the expense of
other populations
based on either pre-existing conditions
or not based on pre-existing conditions
based instead
on simple choice that people are making
on an individual level
you are doomed to to do violence to the
people who
who are supposedly privileged in your
society okay now here's the thing if you
catch any of this
then people get very angry if you catch
the fact that this has
moved into all aspects of our society
including the military including the
training of our defense contractors
then people get very very upset with you
which is why for example
eddie glaude who's just a he's a
professor if you remember where where he
cloud is a
is a professor i believe he's at
princeton
which is kind of incredible considering
how unimpressive his writings are and
i've read many of them
uh eddie glad speaking with chris ruffo
and rufo is detailing how critical race
theory is in fact
racist and glad you start rolling his
eyes because of course you're not
supposed to catch on to what all of this
is here is eddie glaub versus chris roof
on msnbc it's not accurate to say that
i'm not concerned about the substance
i've written policy papers white papers
i've written investigative reports i'm
deeply concerned about the substance but
what i'm concerned about and what
millions of parents are really concerned
about is things that are happening in
hundreds of public schools
in illinois and chicago uh where they're
teaching kindergartner
children as young as kindergarten that
whiteness is the devil and attempts to
lure people
into it with the promise of stolen land
and stolen riches
that's a book that's being used in
hundreds of schools and people
don't think that's right okay glaude is
rolling his eyes at that but ruffo is
correct there isn't in fact a children's
book directed at your kids
that teaches them that your whiteness is
a deal that you effectively make with
satan
in which you get all these wonderful
privileges all you have to give up is
your soul
okay but again the eye rolling from the
media is not a true eye roll because
they know it's true it's just they
object to you noticing this they don't
like that you're noticing this
and by the way it's the biggest teachers
unions in the country the american
federation of teachers randy weingarten
one of the worst people in the country i
mean just truly a bad person with regard
to shutting down schools with regard to
disadvantaging children the aft's randy
weingarten says
if people break the law states are now
passing laws to ban critical race theory
as they should because again it is a
practical it is not a theory
it's not a way of viewing the world it
is a it is an activist indoctrination
tool
okay randy weingarten says if teachers
violate the law then we will defend them
in court that is it
we will do that mark my words
our union will defend any member
who gets in trouble for teaching honest
history
we have a legal defense fund ready to go
and we were preparing for litigation as
we speak
well i'm sure they would not have
similar thoughts about teaching you know
traditional american history if you got
fired for that over at the aft
and there is an indoctrination movement
on the left and it has moved
throughout our schools it is it is truly
amazing and by the way it does not just
apply with regard to race
it also obviously applies with regard to
sexual identity we'll get to that in
just
one moment because every form of
radicalism has set its roots deep
into the bedrock of the fundamental
institutions of american life
first let's talk about the fact that
this summer hopefully we'll all be
back on the move i mean you should be
okay life is back to normal and if
you're not treating it as normal you're
doing it wrong
well that means that you need a great
pair of wireless earbuds and whether you
are just going out and enjoying the day
and listening to some tunes
or whether you're listening to podcasts
like this one whatever it is that you
are doing you need a great pair of
wireless earbuds and raycons can help
make your day better a pair of raycon
wireless earbuds in your ears can make
all the difference no matter what you
are listening to
yet crisp powerful beats at half the
price of other premium audio brands
raycons look great they feel even better
they come in a range of cool colors with
customizable gel tips included for a
comfortable in-ear fit
and raycons are built to go wherever you
go with quick and seamless bluetooth
pairing and
a compact charging case listen up raycon
is offering 15
off all their products from my listeners
here's what you've got to do to go get
it go to buyrecon.com
ben there you will get 15 off your
entire recon order
it's such a good deal you'll want to
grab a pair and a spare that is 15
off at byraycon dot com slash ben once
again that is b u y
r a y c o n dot com slash ben by raycon
dot com slash ben go check them out
right now by raycon dot com
slash ben for 15 off alrighty too many
americans have forgotten
a pretty basic fact freedom isn't free
now price has historically been human
life which is why
in honor of america's independence this
week the daily wire is celebrating the
men who sacrificed themselves for our
freedom with our newest podcast
america's forgotten heroes the podcast
boasts
seven episodes detailing the lives of
seven legendary men who risked it all
for america one of those men was frank
luke
an ace pilot with a tendency to fly
alone in disobey orders he shot his way
into history after taking down 17
enemy aircraft over the course of 12
furious days those weren't just any
aircraft they were the observation
balloons which were by far the most
heavily defended targets of the war
luke's final flight took place when he
was only 21 years old after shooting
down three more enemy balloons he was
shot fatally by german troops there's no
doubt frank luke was an american patriot
whose fervent personality matched his
passion for a country he deserves to be
remembered subscribe now
to america's forgotten heroes on apple
podcast spotify or anywhere you listen
the last episode is out today for a
total of seven episodes too many heroes
never receive the recognition they
deserve
sharing their stories with you on this
independence day holiday is our small
tribute
to their heroism if you like what you
hear leave a five-star review help us
share these incredible stories thanks
for listening
thank you to the heroes that made such
an excellent podcast possible you're
listening to the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
it's not merely that our schools have
been taken over by a critical race
theory they've also been taken over by
gender theory
because gender theory is an aspect of
critical theory more broadly critical
theory is the idea
that it comes out of deconstructionism
in the 1960s particularly foucault
the basic idea is that all institutions
all language is the language of power
gender theory suggests that gender is
completely disconnected from biological
sex that it is a social construct
designed
to re-enshrine hierarchies of power just
as
critical race theory suggests the same
about our hierarchies of power and
america's institutions
gender theory suggests more broadly that
all notions of male and female are in
and of themselves
a social construct completely
dispensable and not only dispensable
they must be torn down
very important to tear that stuff down
so that people can live freer
and better lives free of the
expectations of a society that represses
them
that that cramps their style
we need to allow people the freedom to
self-identify from the time they are in
kindergarten and
and the real idea here is that you can
overthrow all systems of power which are
embedded
in patriarchal systems if all you do is
just overthrow basic notions of human
biology science
physics virtually any sort of verifiable
data
and this sort of stuff is being taught
in our schools as well
the reality is unfortunately that the
aft the nea all of these educational
assorted unions have decided to
indoctrinate
our kids in nearly every radical left
theory they can imagine
and a lot of this is now being
legislated into law for example in the
state of california
the state of california does in fact
require k-6
lgbtq plus agenda items be taught to
small small children
in fact the aclu has an entire
guide to how to comply with the
so-called california healthy youth act
which is
about as much of a misnomer as i can
imagine it requires school districts to
provide students with integrated
comprehensive accurate and unbiased
sexual health and hiv prevention
education
it must be taught in grades seven
through twelve at least once in middle
school and once in high school it can
also be taught
in any grade k through 6 inclusive but
it is not
restricted just to sexual health and hiv
prevention of course
it is also a values teaching
seminar it is an attempt to cram down
particularly socially leftist values on
kids
all in the name of the health of the
kids by the way because confusing kids
about their gender at the age of five is
definitely good for them
teaching kids at the age of five that
there is nothing beneficial about
male-female relationships for the
production
and rearing of children and also that
male and female are completely arbitrary
categories to which
you personally could belong any category
you choose
none of that is going to have any
deleterious effect on children or future
generations
none of this has to do with with raising
a healthier crop of small children by
the way
as a father of small children i
guarantee you that what this really has
to do
is with adults who have decided they
need to indoctrinate the next generation
in order to accept whatever they decide
to engage in sexually that day
or whatever they decide to identify as
that day it's about remolding society in
a radical left-wing hierarchical mold
in which the people at the top of the
hierarchy are the people who purport to
be the greatest victims
according to the aclu here is what
sexual health and hiv prevention
instruction in grade k-6 must include
the following they must be they must
affirmatively recognize different sexual
orientations in kindergarten and be
inclusive of same-sex relationships
in discussions and examples k through
six you must teach about gender
gender expression gender identity and
the harm of negative gender stereotypes
you have to teach presumably gender
fluidity they have to be free of bias
based on actual or perceived disability
gender gender identity gender expression
race or ethnicity nationality religion
or sexual orientation
additional content that may be taught in
k-6
include things can be taught right aloud
information about accessing resources
for sexual and reproductive health care
it can be taught k-6 in california
also you're allowed to teach kids about
effectively abortion reproductive
so-called reproductive health
and gender theory is deeply embedded in
all this stuff and it's recommended
okay this is not an outlying theory that
is pushed by the left it is recommended
by people writing
for the american federation of teachers
in 2019 there's an article
brought out by the official journal of
the american federation of teachers
which is the second largest teachers
union in the united states after the nea
there's an article by jill herman
wilmarth and caitlin ryan
talking it's called reading and teaching
the rainbow
and the affirmative case that it makes
is that you should
use elementary school classrooms as
indoctrination centers for lgbtq
plus agenda items they say people are
sometimes shocked by the notion that
teachers should address lesbian gay
bisexual transgender and queer topics in
elementary schools
maybe they think children those ages are
too young that those conversations are
better had at home
or that the whole topic is simply
inappropriate this is not what we
believe
at all instead we simply want them to
talk about the diversity of families and
relationships and communities in ways
that include lgbt lgbtq
plus people after all public schools are
for everyone except if you're religious
or you hold traditional values or
believe in natural law then they're not
for you but everyone else
they're definitely for if children
themselves don't have lgbtq parents
perhaps they have a peer with two moms
at daycare or a relative who comes out
as gay or maybe they've heard a story
about transgender rights on the news
so now it is the job of schools if a kid
hears something on the news or could
hear something on the news we need to
teach kids about that immediately in all
possible contexts
i don't think that this is what the left
actually believes by the way
okay the the best part of this article
is how you should teach small children
about gender
again they're talking about
kindergartners i'm not five-year-olds i
have a boy who's five
i would never allow my kid within 30
feet of people like this
you'd have to be out of your damn mind
and these are people who are writing
long
pieces for the american federation of
teachers the american educator spring
2019 quote
if we help students see there aren't
strict rules about what girls and boys
can do or
how girls and boys should be then we
help to blur those divisions between
categories
and and here i'm saying yes that that's
a bad thing you don't want to blur the
divisions between boys and girls because
this creates gender confusion that is
unmerited and unwarranted but
they think that it's a good thing to
blur the lines okay this blurring
can help students learn to respect
people who live these those categories
differently
when people disrupt any of the matrix
categories through their gender identity
through their gender expression or with
whom and how they might fall in love
they are queering disrupting and
expanding the heterosexual matrix to
make more kinds of lives and loves
visible
teaching in this way a method that we
call questioning categories means
helping your students investigate how
both people in the real world and
characters and books
disrupt the heterosexual matrix and to
what effect we believe such
questioning helps students become more
aware of and more sensitive to the
multiple ways of
doing gender or being in relationships
don't worry it has nothing to do with
sex it has nothing to do with sexual
confusion or gender confusion
it's just good for your kids it's just
good and if you notice that they are
teaching
bullcrap gender theory that was brought
about by a bunch of
morons in the 1960s pretending at being
intelligent
commentators if you point out that there
is no scientific basis for what they are
talking about right here
and that it has nothing to do with the
overall health of school children what
it has to do instead is promoting a
broader social agenda
on the back of a small very small group
of people
who have some problems that cannot be
solved by
shaping the entire society around those
problems if you do that
then then the society if you notice
then they become very very angry all of
this is is now more and more embedded
in our in the life of our nation yeah
apathetic people in the middle so far
they sort of okay it doesn't bother me
what's the big deal
okay it is a big deal the nea adopted
a measure in 2019 saying that the nea
would create model legislative language
that state affiliates can use to lobby
for a k-12 cross-content curriculum that
is lgbtq plus inclusive
this is why when you see people people i
respect who say that state legislation
should not be involved
in banning crt or banning gender theory
from k-12 classrooms
the left ain't shy about this they are
attempting to cram this down
on your kids because after all
everything is an emergency and if
everything is an emergency
then totalitarian power implemented at
the expense of your
children is totally justified that
indeed is the goal
alrighty we'll be back here later today
with an additional hour of content in
the meantime go check out the michael
moles show today he discusses the crime
spikes in san francisco and chicago you
can hear more details about that
over on michael's show that's available
right now i'm ben shapiro this is the
ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliott feld executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover
production manager pavel wydowsky
associate producer bradford carrington
host producer justin barber the show is
edited by adam sciavitz
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant jessica kranz
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
the white house plans to go door-to-door
to get people jabbed with the vaccine
crime spikes in san francisco in chicago
and a new study shows democrats are more
likely to dehumanize republicans check
it out on the michael knowles show